okay guys okay let's see here okay okay
um first thing I was doing is [ __ ]
just put a tree right here I get good
good good good good we need some [ __ ]
water good [ __ ] electricity yeah dad
Canada makes me get a second water right
here really a lot what sure you could
start out with let's see here I need
some [ __ ] house says yes get get oh I
just oh [ __ ] all right through this oh
shut okay production fish farm I need
water and organic waste and I do not
have that oh wait no I do have a kind of
waste and have water but I need some
money real quick whoo they got where the
store they're making it [ __ ] hard yep
there we go
just make some news for ya okay see ya
[ __ ] anymore lecture say [ __ ] anywhere
fish wait fresh air I'm gonna fresh air
12 okay I need more vegetables well this
is moving [ __ ] fast okay um I need
more gray water and any more [ __ ]
fertilizer this is insane how do I get
no cuz i'm on the fish farm now how do i
get rid of organic waste gotta be
something right greenhouse gas no no
[ __ ] it i'll let the waist go up right
oh wait no I need more organic waste Liz
what is he using that
Oh fish fish guys okay let's see here
let's see ya chase ass a keg yeah yeah
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] no this using organic
waste yeah I [ __ ] up there how do i
how do I produce more oh apartments a
large apartment there we go we got this
in the bag [ __ ] we got this in the
[ __ ] bag [ __ ] any more money though
you say they say the cellos I deal with
every day I said okay markets makes so
much money though so when I'm like here
it was shut he's the chosen well wonky
but you know I like a walkie I can't get
good again
now more [ __ ] like yesterday you
promised said you don't have a dick
balance ok and now i just need loser
come on Shane gently leisure change from
a [ __ ] mmm I need right there [ __ ] a
okay come on yes yes again how it is
going up and that is basically um
challenge for [ __ ] ok ok ok I would
just get a fast forward so we get to vm
oh yeah